[Música]
duzentos anos de combustíveis fósseis
nos levarão um beco sem saída
o aquecimento global a elevação do nível
dos oceanos poluição nas cidades estão
chegando no limite do que o planeta pode
aguentar a pergunta que quero endereçar
aqui hoje é como a tecnologia pode
ajudar a resolver esse problema
o consumo de energia no mundo está
crescendo de forma acelerada nos últimos
25 anos cresceu mais de 60% crescerá
mais 43% nos próximos 25 apenas esse
crescimento é equivalente a 800 usinas
de itaipu
como vamos gerar toda essa energia mas
combustíveis fósseis
será que a tecnologia não pode trazer
soluções mais inovadoras para gerá los a
energia que precisamos
a energia solar é o futuro
a fonte mais abundante de energia um ano
de instalação na terra equivale ao
consumo do planeta por um ano
muitos de vocês já ouviram essas
afirmações
mas como realmente podemos comparar a
fonte solar com as demais fontes
esse gráfico consegue fazer isso de uma
forma simples
ele mostra disponibilidade de cada
energia existente
do lado esquerdo de combustíveis fósseis
carvão gás natural petróleo e se vão
acabar
do lado direito o potencial anual de
cada uma das fontes renováveis pequeno
ponto azul é hidráulica bastante
relevante no brasil mais limitada no
mundo temos a eólica com grande
potencial e tem crescido muito no brasil
e finalmente a solar com duas mil e 800
vezes o consumo atual de energia
conclusão
se quisermos reduzir nossa dependência
de combustíveis fósseis
precisamos investir pesadamente energia
solar
de fato com aproximadamente 5% da área
do deserto do saara
podemos gerar energia para todo o
planeta ea boa notícia é que o brasil é
um país bastante privilegiado em energia
fotovoltaica ea energia só a toda a o
território do país em uma boa insolação
[Música]
yoo área de instalação no brasil é 40%
melhor do que a melhora na alemanha
então resolvemos criar uma comparação de
potencial solar
desenvolvemos uma métrica e potencial
solar uma conta simples apenas
multiplicando a inflação média de cada
país pela área e aí selecionamos quatro
países para comparar uma alemanha é
relativamente pequena e tem pouca
insolação entre os quatro países ela tem
dois por cento do potencial solar
o brasil é grande e tem muita insolação
71%
agora vamos comparar com energia solar
efetivamente instalada em cada um destes
quatro países alemanha possui 82 por
cento no brasil 10
pra mim isso parece uma grande
oportunidade
vocês concordam no brasil com área
equivalente a 60% do lago de furnas
podemos gerar energia elétrica para
todas as residências do país
por que não usar essa área é
subutilizada para gerar energia e ainda
economizar água
então como eu me envolvi nesse desafio
em 2011 estava morando já há vários anos
no reino unido trabalhando justamente
com inovação e lançamento de produtos de
alta tecnologia no mercado
fui convidado a voltar ao brasil para
encarar esse sonho
no começo era um dos cinco pessoas numa
sala do centro de bh um power point nas
mãos
pensamos como podemos entrar nesse jogo
vamos investir em tecnologias
tradicionais já estão mais estabelecidas
ou buscar tecnologias ainda em
desenvolvimento mas com maior potencial
de crescimento
decidimos que a melhor opção é investir
no futuro é investir em tecnologia de
cultivos
era realmente uma aposta de futuro
avaliamos também que para o sucesso as
tecnologias fotovoltaicas nas cidades
além de eficiência e custo é muito
importante design algum produto que
agregasse valor de construções e que
pudesse ser facilmente instalado nas
estruturas já existentes
entendemos que o futuro da energia
fotovoltaica é o painel o pv painel
fotovoltaico orgânico um painel impresso
em plástico flexível e leve com cores
variadas e semi transparente
aqui nesse rolo podemos gerar a energia
para cinco residências médias para gerar
energia equivalente um painel
tradicional estaríamos de 700 quilos de
painel no menor peso traz várias
vantagens
agora vamos ver algumas outras vantagens
da tecnologia o pv tem primeiro um
processo produtivo de baixo custo
trata-se basicamente de uma impressão
semelhante a impressão do jornal
segundo o uso de pouca energia na
fabricação
o painel pv requer dez vezes menos
energia para ser fabricado do que os
painéis tradicionais e por isso é
tecnologia fotovoltaica mais verde que
existe em terceiro o uso de materiais
abundantes na natureza
a tinta que utilizamos para transformar
a luz em energia elétrica é um polímero
à base de carbono
o hidrogênio por isso ele é chamado de
eletrônica e fotovoltaico orgânico além
disso como fazemos um processo de
impressão novas tintas mais eficiente
que estão sendo desenvolvidas como a
prova escrita podem ser impressas no
mesmo equipamento que já temos como
tornar esse sonho realidade
foi importante não reinventar a roda
contratamos excelente cientistas
engenheiros e técnicos do brasil junto
com profissionais de vários países com
experiência na tecnologia
chegamos até 11 nacionalidades
trabalhando conosco
isso não está a tap tinha 30 pessoas
também precisamos sem inovadores na
montagem da infraestrutura e os recursos
escassos e precisamos improvisar
nosso primeiro laboratório foi num
depósito de caixas que temos que
reformar não tinha energia suficiente
para ligar os equipamentos então
alugamos um gerador
o desenvolvimento chegou a ser
interrompido por falta de diesel no
gerador
o gerente de pesquisa quer da inglaterra
achava surreal o tipo de desafio que nós
enfrentávamos nosso segundo e atual
laboratório também era um prédio
abandonado que finalmente transformamos
numa das maiores e mais modernas
estruturas de sala limpa do brasil
ok mas pra que serve o pv o problema
essa tecnologia resolve
apesar dos painéis tradicionais serem
muito importante para o crescimento da
energia fotovoltaica no mundo
ele possui algumas limitações para
aplicação em grandes centros urbanos
além disso tem um design não tão
atraentes
no caso do pv vislumbramos um futuro
onde toda a cidade estará gerando
energia fotovoltaica um conceito que
chamamos de energia é vil e todas as
superfícies podem gerar energia
o fachadas de prédios vão gerar energia
além disso o pv reduz a incidência de
raios infravermelho e com isso o uso do
ar condicionado
esse prédio será inaugurado em janeiro
em são paulo
o escritório de maio deixar porque não
colocar uma bandeira do brasil gerando
energia solar na fachada do ministério
das minas e energias
afinal podemos imprimir de várias cores
e que tal o pv no carro além de reduzir
o consumo de combustível ea emissão de
co2
ao estacionar no sol ele pode manter um
ventilador funcionando e assim o carro
vai ter uma estufa quando você voltar na
hora do almoço para dirigi lo
na verdade existem várias outras
aplicações
esse vídeo ilustra um pouco como
enxergamos a estrutura completamente
diverso o
com 15 empresas que são grandes o único
embaixadas voz de gasolina copiar o
código além de qualcomm em um estádio de
futebol e porque não gera energia na
praia de copacabana
[Música]
a imaginação é o limite
acredito e pra reduzir a nossa
dependência e combustíveis fósseis
inovação e tecnologia são a melhor forma
e energia solar eo pv são cruciais nessa
solução no futuro espero que as pessoas
façam a seguinte pergunta com tanta
energia solar disponível porque ainda
utilizavam os combustíveis poluentes
para gerar energia e como a tecnologia
pode ajudar isso pode ajudar a resolver
esse problema
nós vamos imprimir energia limpa
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]